je viens vous raconter l'histoire des
grands plus grand glacier qui ont
couvert et qui couvre notre planète et
surtout le cric nous pousse aujourd'hui
ces glaciers sur la vulnérabilité de
notre société contemporaine mois voici à
quoi ressemblait la plaire il y a à
quinze mille ans lors de la dernière
période glaciaire
la température était 8 degrés plus
froides qu'actuellement et deux énormes
calotte polaire c'est à dire deux
couches de glace épaisse de plusieurs
milliers de mètres recouvrait le nord de
l'amérique et la scandinavie c'est
calotte se sont formés par accumulation
neige sur les continents et en
conséquence le niveau de la mer et 120
mètres plus bas
quelques millions d'humains peuplent la
planète organisée en troupe de chasseurs
cueilleurs du fait des variations
naturelles de l'orbité terrestre
le climat se réchauffe progressivement
les calottes fonde le niveau de la mer
monte
il ya 5000 ans de ces grandes calottes
de l'ère glaciaire ne subsiste plus que
le groenland au nord et l'antarctique au
sud
l'homme poursuit le développement de sa
société
au 19ème siècle on découvre
l'antarctique et les avancées dans les
sciences de la terre permettent de mieux
comprendre cette alternance entre
périodes froides et période chaude qui
ont jalonné l'histoire de la planète
nous voilà à la fin du xxème siècle nous
sommes maintenant près de sept milliards
d'humains habitants dans cette société
globale est interconnecté que nous
connaissons les grandes variations des
calottes semble bien comprises elles
réagissent très lentement sur des
échelles de temps linéaire millénaire
pardon et dans le contexte du
réchauffement climatique que nous
connaissons actuellement
les variations de leur volume devrait
peu impacté le niveau de la mer
et c'est à ce moment là que la lumière
s'allume les satellites commence à
scruter les pôles on a enfin une vision
globale de l'antarctique et surtout on
peut suivre son évolution
surprise en péninsule d'abord deux
grandes plateformes de glace se dément
c'est se démantèle en quelques semaines
en 1995 le larsson à son voisin le
larsson besuye en 2002 et les satellites
permettent aussi de mesurer la vitesse
d'écoulement de cette glace
particulièrement lente au centre de la
calotte de l'ordre du mètre par an la
glace se canalise en longs fleuves qui
viennent jusqu'à la mer des vitesses de
quelques kilomètres par an là encore on
peut suivre son évolution dans la région
d'amundsen de glaciers notamment le
glacier de pine island qui en une
dizaine d'années voit sa vitesse passer
de trois à quatre kilomètres par an et
rejette d'autant plus de glace dans
l'océan
aujourd'hui les calottes polaires que ce
soit l'antarctique où le groënland
contribuer à élever le niveau de la mer
d'un millimètre par an alors que cette
contribution est nuls
il y a vingt ans désagréable surprise
d'autant plus inquiétante que les
connaissances amassé jusqu'à la fin du
xxème siècle ne nous permettent pas de
comprendre les raisons de ces
changements nous permettent pas de
savoir si ces accélérations vont
continuer ralentir avec quelles
conséquences
ce qui était inenvisageable devient
réalité c'est un véritable changement de
paradigme auxquels est confrontée la
société la communauté scientifique que
nous disent les tout derniers
développements
on va regarder une coupe schématique
verticale du glacier island on peut voir
tout d'abord que ce glacier repose sur
un socle qui en dessous du niveau de la
mer autre particularité il est beaucoup
moins profond à proximité de la côte
qu'il ne l'est plus à l'intérieur des
terres
cette configuration est typique est
capital on va examiner plus en détail ce
point qui marque l'extension de la
calotte et donc la quantité de glace qui
est stocké sur le continent si l'océan
se réchauffe
il est à même de faire bouger ce point
mais il y a aussi des mécanismes
internes pour les comprendre on va
imaginer que ce point est en fait un
cycliste qui aujourd'hui en haut de la
côte
si vous poussez légèrement ce cycliste
il va avancer puis ralentir et s'arrêter
mais si jamais vous poussez un tout
petit peu trop et qu'ils entament la
cote alors il va dévaler la pente et une
s'arrêter qu'au fond de la vallée
aujourd'hui le glacier de pine island
est dans la pente et son voisin le
glacier toi x semble prendre le même
chemin
il semble donc vraisemblable que cette
partie de l'antarctique ne puisse
exister durablement que dans une
configuration proche de l'actuel ou bien
bascule est alors s'il bascule c'est
plusieurs mètres de haut niveau des mers
qui seront ajoutés or il s'avère que
l'essentiel de nos infrastructures se
trouvent à proximité des côtes new york
par exemple comme tant d'autres
métropoles serait dramatiquement et
durablement impacté de plus près de 60%
de la population habite à moins de 60 km
du littoral
si le niveau de la mer venait à
augmenter de manière importante
on verrait des migrations massives
mettant à mal notre société nos
démocraties vous savez nous sommes sur
le chemin de ces grands changements
et comme on vient de le voir ces grands
changements ne sont pas linéaires c'est
à dire qu'une toute petite perturbation
supplémentaire peut amener à des grands
changements importants et durables
l'instabilité de l'antarctique de
l'ouest en est une illustration brûlante
criante dont on voit les premiers signes
sous nos yeux
quel est notre marge de manoeuvre on
sait palestine mais ne rien faire c'est
choisir de voir ces changements se
mettre en place
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
l'environnement
je vais vous demander d'en profiter pour
penser et réfléchir ce que vous citoyens
pouvaient faire pour décarbonés vos
propres activités
est ce qu'il est raisonnable de prendre
votre voiture pour le moindre
déplacement de prendre l'avion pour vos
prochaines vacances d'acheter cette
maison mal isolée à 30 km de votre
travail
évidemment vous n'êtes que le maillon
d'une chaîne animer cette chaîne
soutenait ouvertement fortement toutes
les initiatives faites en sorte que la
grande conférence internationale à paris
en décembre soit une réussite
choisissez notre avenir l'avenir de nos
enfants
ne rien faire c'est j'en suis sûr
choisir un avenir pour nous n'avons pas
besoin merci